[Music]
coming at you live from the roof of the
Spreckels theater in downtown San Diego
it's live at Conan Cod featuring
comedians Joel Kim booster Flula Borg
and marina Franklin and now you're live
at Conan Con host Moses store hello and
welcome to live at Kona con I am on
competing medications if you're not
already make sure you're following at
Kona con to stay updated on all things
that Conan is doing down here at Comic
Con I got my correspondence in the field
grabbing the best stuff we're posting
that on at Kona Con in addition to that
we're streaming here live on Facebook
and YouTube so send us your questions
and we are legitimately live because
look at the time my correspondents were
out in the field they're grabbing juicy
stuff for us all day and on this show
we're gonna go through a few of those
things that we found everything else is
again on at Kona Con so I'm joined by
the very funny
Joel Kim Booster marina Franklin Flula
Borg and more for your live at Kona Con
thing the best side gig of the world
Andy Richter pleased to be here I'm
happy to be here I'm happy I'm concerned
it's live at Andy Kahn you just rushed
up here this is our after show you just
you just wrapped the show right and you
ran up here I just wanted to show off my
legs on the Internet no that's you're
wearing this under your suit at all
times I don't know I actually I I was
just saying before we started that I
should have dressed better but this is
what I wore to work today because yeah I
don't I don't have like a job where I
have to dress like a grown-up except for
an hour so they're comfortable I just
dress like a toddler because I can it
would look weird if you're on this
Nickelodeon set yes you know yes in a
full suit you look like your father here
to give us a ride home
I immediately was drawn to this yeah
well I don't know what it looks like
sorry ports on a giant game all right
like a robot belly button hmm or
something else or something else you
know I can't really say cuz I'm not
supposed to Express we love you too
wrong you know no strong opinions if you
could just take the softball opinions
anyway
it looks like a cloaca there we go give
a taxicab had a cloaca is your fourth
year at comic-con it is down here it is
have you ever
I already feel like I already know the
answer to this is a hard no but have you
ever walked the convention center floor
no that's the right answer I have never
done the right any of it the closest I
ever got was I was I had done a
fundraiser like a music education
fundraiser I hosted and and the composer
Michael Giacchino who's like a amazing
musician was doing a I think it was a
Star Trek movie he did the score of a
Star Trek movie and like down by the
waterfront they were showing the movie
and then having like a orchestra live
orchestra company at a movie yeah alive
and he asked me to come and I said
because this was it was right around the
same time and he asked me to come so I
was like sure I'd love to and I even had
like a special you know like access pass
and just getting close to - I was with
my assistant we walked down there and I
got like within half a mile of it and I
was like no it's the immediate anxiety
it's like it's two beats people mixed in
with like super fans yeah yeah out of
pushing
yes I'm yeah no I and I'm not like I'm
51 years old I don't know what a lot of
this stuff you really are you
legitimately in a non show business way
look great thank you thank you well you
know those satan packs are great that's
great The Devil's and Brander it's how I
shot right through the middle
rate so I spend a little bit of my own
blood to Andy every month in the mail
and he makes some risk of it
he doesn't send very much under the
upright in general it's my booster awful
people just fall out around the
perimeters of comic-con even if you
don't go to the convention center
there's just people walking around
pedicabs we've been under one of those
teddy cabs no I never have I feel too
bad for them I just it just feels like I
have enough guilt
already that I don't need to like have
someone actually exert themselves
physically to locomote me from place to
place right people burning calories for
you here it's their passion really just
jump off the roof onto a pedicab I'll do
a pedicab they would definitely
presearch have you been under one of
those electric scooters that are
infesting the street just today just
today because we had one in the show
spoiler alert we had one on the show and
I wrote it and it was pretty fun but
it's pretty it's danger yeah somebody
said and it's like that's too much and
they're all on the sidewalks they should
be on the street yeah yeah but um yeah
put them in the middle of the lanes yeah
of the streets oh well I really want it
they got to get in traffic and but it
does seem like the fact that you can
just charge you like just pick one up
wherever it is which time are always
weird because like if you go to the
grocery store on one there's no you
don't know that it's going to be there
when you get back there's just street
corners where they're piled up and like
a are they really it really is yeah
seiyya t of like not having it when you
come out it's like having a bike in a
bad neighborhood not getting home and I
also can tell you from having children
they're a little bit older for them now
but walking through like a dark garage
when there's razor scooters on the floor
it's the like there were so many times I
have thrown so many razor scooters just
from like stepping on them or tripping
over them
I know you me cuz like it catapults the
handle up there it someone a wreck when
they're sitting down there awkward sort
of things ever and they're just there
like a tripping magnet and yeah it is
weird like thing between a skateboard
and a bike yeah you know and I saw a man
on a skateboard today and I was like
thank God good for you what happened to
roller skating it back bring it ready
no rollerblading just good old roller
skater dressed for it thank you Dan
adieu people are pretty well dressed on
the show today transition yes the Castro
predator was on the show they were yeah
so that was pretty exciting person panel
not really understand it's you know what
and you know it's what's what is sucky
about that setup and there's nothing you
can do about it yeah
you can't hear anybody you just can't I
mean there's enough noise going on in
the theater but like when they're you
know when it's my job my job there is to
crack wise and I can't hear what your
wisecrack has not heard ones like what
did you say and then everyone in the
audience because it was the Castro
predator he's walking with Conan pop
figure and watch away with predator one
they did down there oh yeah I was down
there for the predator panel so that was
pretty awesome
was it yeah not a lot of predator
outfits that were good unfortunately a
lot of people were trying to use dreads
yes as part of their predator costume
and I was like now you don't get away
because having dress rights a Berkeley
student that way every okay yeah so we
actually had because you were giving
away pop figure costume yeah this is the
this is the pop figure right here it
kind of looks to me like like bedpan
Conan yeah and there are like BMX comon
cone BMX Conan that just came back from
Jamaica where they get that like that
one beaded braid right exactly like
okay okay so every audience member got
one of those they did not figures and
the just for the show hands of QVC yeah
everyone what do they do anything
special like why do people want these
just so like it sits in places from what
you mean it fits in places like a shelf
on someone's shelf that's what he meant
a bookshelf exactly no and well in the
crazy thing to me about this kind of
thing and this and it's just because I
don't understand this like people don't
even take them out of the box like the
other yeah it's very it's a it's a toy
and I mean I you know even as an old man
I feel like well if it's a little doll
you'd want to at least but Fox goes on
the okay goes I've never been good at
like thinking about like because I
collected comic book-y and beanie babies
and I was always like rip that tag off
and everyone would freak out and be like
you can't that's worth nothing now and
it's like it was worth nothing before
thank you so much for coming up here and
thank you guys for doing this it's of
course thank you Andy well you come see
us again
up here I'm a hard promise for you right
now I know that's why I'm you know I'm
in this town alone either when the cat's
away I'm playing all right my hotel room
and stared at wall which is right there
that's that's that window right there
what we see you in there yeah you see
you shouting at yourself I didn't get
your wisecrack in I gotta do my nude
window stand Andy get to it huge thank
you to Andy Richter bye everyone
we really appreciate it Andy right
corners the comment sections going crazy
we are live on YouTube and Facebook huge
thank you to Andy Richter thank you so
much for stopping by look at that that's
exactly where that goes that's what
that's for
goodbye walks off into the sunset I just
want to give a quick shout out to our
friends at DirecTV now that made this
whole thing possible that's why we get
to be up here so you know DirecTV now
it's bringing you insider access to all
of your favorite Conan Cohn things if
you're tired of being trapped in
smothering year-long contracts and some
cable guys stomping into your house
while you install some bulky Hardware
just so you can watch your favorite show
well DirecTV now is a dish free with no
annual contract no bulky hardware
DirecTV now lets you watch your
must-have live TV shows networks and
more from wherever you are have 10 or 11
hours to kill not a problem with DIRECTV
now you can stream your favorite shows
right from where you are wherever you
are in that line that weight will go by
in no time no matter what you like
DirecTV now has more for your live at
Kona con thing and speaking of live at
comic-con this is a huge problem for the
comment section to that you're just like
what did whirling I'm crushing this is
this I will treat it like a delicate
flower here look look at that
that'll be displayed I'll kill this cuz
I snaps when I go crazy about that you
you this was the official first day down
at comic-con yes yesterday was like
people are setting up but Flula you were
down there oh yes in the tarantula in
the trenches things got pretty exciting
for you high excitement high excitement
everything was crazy people jumping
people sweating people eating that's
there could be anywhere that could just
be a tryout I'm just telling you what I
observed this and I'm just observing
report today so yes I'm it was to go to
comic-con I not just a a middle school
gym no I just go where the Waze tells me
to go okay yes you were down and you got
a photo with some moon cakes oh great
let's take a look at that what is this
moon cakes Oh show outer space which is
actually a cone akan produced shipping
final space final space what'd I say
I don't know outers
which outer space where they could be
more exciting yeah a bunch of mine made
this show it's a very funny animated
show a wonderful show yes yes and you
got your face in there I said casting
they're doing down there yeah yeah they
said to everyone just poke out and see
what happens
yeah I poked out just give the deadest
look in your eyes that's the most still
I've ever seen you yawn that folks cuz
it is a photo it is a photo yes and and
he got me there and then you also went
down and you you visited one of the most
exciting things about comic-con oh I do
mind the lime yeah so many lines where
do they go nobody knows we usually say
it over a banner however they would go
okay I don't read those okay well I
think we have we actually have some
footage of you in a low-lying photo but
you go visit wanna see flew in line down
at the comic-con I see so many lines
here at comic-con let's find out what
people are waiting for hey guys what are
we waiting for
Oh Lula Bora coaching them in that
hostage video yes this is fine everyone
smiled hold up a newspaper yes yes it
was great they were ready to see Joe
Manganiello I don't know what this was
he's a Magic Mike yeah close personal
friend of mine we go way back we were in
a summer stock production of The Music
Man yeah that's where we met originally
so I was actually inside I didn't have
to wait in line because you my close
personal friend Joe we're gonna see that
a little bit later
yeah we got some but you got content
with that in where were you I don't know
a silly German rube root aren't we all
supposed to get in yes she got these the
are you showing your your Conan Pass no
when you get in I'm sure there's all
access Conan but you're just hoping that
there'll be kindness I'm using charisma
no this isn't this is not one of these
German conventions where it's just a
smile and a wink it's the end yeah -
winks and one smile as always yes yeah
yeah yeah that's the password
yeah so did you get to the front of the
line you got nothing you got just these
people that look like they were just
waiting for essentially a tender greens
yeah I was something somebody look like
some organized I just want to see what
people are standing for no reason I want
to know the reason even if I don't
understand the reason I don't know who
John Makabe is but he you saw Gabba
Gabba Yo Gabba Gabba Yo Gabba Gabba
I've never stand in a line just so you
know I'm not and I like it what do you
do in the line I cut the line I make my
own line yeah I like this and they
always they tell me what are you doing
this is the line I'm like oh this is the
line yeah back to the future where we're
going we don't need roads no rules here
that's what that means
yeah and then you also visited a
Deadpool dance party yeah I just write
Deadpool was SIA and some stuffy bunnies
within some bears
nobody was dancing it's very confusing
okay so I think you actually did get
into that so let's take a look at Flula
at the Deadpool dance party okay and I'm
going to go inside and get more of my
Deadpool thing and other things now
oh man just got back from that deadpool
dance party I show Deadpool my best move
the statue well okay so full disclosing
yeah we hit record as we started to go
and then I thought it was on start and
then stopped but we hit stop as we
entered and then start as we left so
there's no footage of me - they another
crucial stop but we have to get that yes
there with the statute those bumpers
okay am I doing this right is this is I
mean talk about rhythm thank you thank
you yeah robot without the robot a
broken robots a broke bot it's a broken
uncharged robot robot oh it's good
does that work for you no when the
German dance clubs no no hasn't worked
yet highly ineffective you think you're
a wax figure yes I just sit say I wait
for people to move me around
okay that's security yes I think you
think you've security already move yes
please leave our location you haven't
blinked in 45 minutes
we are concerned yeah yes I think his
heart may have stopped yeah that's my
move I think I got one more photo what's
coming I know
2009 childhood photo yes you were a
child in 2009 I was this is a this is
you next to the costume from Deadpool oh
who was who I cannot tell Moses who wore
better I mean well it could have been a
model the fanny pack is a dead giveaway
no I mean look at you he never would
have made it never would always a model
Joe he doesn't have it this is a moment
when you are just you should be a ship
unnie
Oh see and they would have said he would
have said they would have said turn give
us a give us an angle and he would have
crumpled crumpled like it like you on
the couch a terrible posture man weeping
pills are kicking no it's not sleeping
I'm just tired of all this content I'm
just kidding I love it and he's back
he's back he's back yeah he was
Maryna you were also down there this is
the first day of I guess people are this
is the first day of people comfortable
going all out with the cosplay
oh yeah class play which by the way I'm
really just learning what that means but
it's it was fun to see all of the
cosplay it's okay it's my time now time
for my comment we claim your time marina
reclaim your time reclaiming my time
[Music]
let's come let's just bring this show to
a grinding halt and just reset and suck
in neck so you were down there and and
you ran into someone that is going all
out this is this is like face off they
do makeup these were models actually oh
nice
we're in position to get makeup so they
were actual models who were made for
that specific makeup yeah okay so let me
get myself yes I saw today I think I
have a little quick little video that
this is so cool I just want to ask this
guy one question can you breathe
[Music]
yeah cuz he couldn't breathe it was I
breathe he really committed to just the
top half of his body the bottom I just
saw like that his boxers and some
Dockers well they had to walk him to the
back for the bottom part they couldn't
do that oh look oh so they were doing it
lime they were like putting that on him
yeah they were doing it live so yeah the
bottom part has to be in private okay
Comic Con or a club you know yeah keep
your bottom right but the top part that
we could see that was being done was
very it was amazing work I don't have
any in the adjectives yeah you know
Cyril did you see that his face oh
they're all in there do you ever gotten
close to him like one year I went you
get really close to them and you just
hear them they breathe like like a pug
we're because your face is under pounds
and pounds of makeup but like I am for
this show you look great come in Turner
9:00 a.m. they spray a thick latex milk
on me baby what you're looking at is a
bowling ball right now just two bowls
yeah - my 40 pounds of makeup I'm
actually four - and this is this is
Joel's stance is really rubbing off on
everyone everyone is a tryptophan
ripping from the ceilings reflection
that is directing - my my eye nose and
so your head is protected claiming my
time bring it - claiming your time
marina you were also down there and you
visited there's a spider-man game that's
coming out and you got very first yeah
cuz I am a gamer you're again I haven't
played spider-man I usually play Batman
and gods of war it's a very serious
gamer and this was really exciting
because the Spider Man which is awesome
is coming out in September in September
okay so more for your gaming thing
here's marina
first time I've ever been able to beat
up a group of men
satisfied
I'm actually salivating
we got one guy left
you were just being like I'm a gamer but
you're actually good at this I got to
cut the lines I had a lot of little boys
really upset with me you made so many
you ruined some boys day Oh online no I
don't wait in lines and they get to see
me this female whooping some serious but
in spider-man and it was awesome because
they learned something I had one little
boy just looking at me like wow she's
amazing
yeah also and then they closed the line
right behind him and they said everyone
needs to go home they tears but whatever
tears whatever that's really cool that
you got to I didn't know you were that
good
yeah I can't do that at all you get a
back of the head kick yeah there's a lot
of like l 3l l 1 l r1 combination yeah
you're talking about vertebras no ok the
actual game oh the buttons are for the
button yeah l1 l2 the second half of
this live stream on Facebook at YouTube
will all just be different body parts of
the vertebrae we're gonna bring a
chiropractor in yes San Diego to find
out what's going on with Joel's back and
what's in it ok so let's go and then
you're you guys are out there tomorrow
again and then Joel you were you were
out there yes oh you are beat because
you were essentially doing you you beat
someone in a push-up contest I did I
beat Joe my good friend my close
personal friend Joe magnet Megan Megan
ello Joe Manganiello yeah from Magic
Mike from us today
I did seven push-ups he was only able to
do five so he was humiliated we didn't
get the footage unfortunately his reps
stole my phone and threw it out onto the
street so I I lost the footage of me
beating him in the push-up contest but
we did get an after picture it would it
would ruin his career that's one of
those lies is like I know we have a
photo from just after the push-up
contest yep there that look at that and
you look and you overlook very relaxed
and just as large as Joe Manganiello
I think there's no like really you cut
off our heads you wouldn't be able to
tell the difference between our two
physiques no it's very hard to tell
who's who in this photo I find and I you
know he was all he was a sore loser
about it but he'll bounce back I've said
he has a lot going on from he actually
just released a new clothing line which
I got a sneak peek of and actually
marina will you hold what this mic for
me no the mic so this is this is Joe
Manganiello shirts the company and it's
it's actually really dope Joe if you can
get one for all of us then I'm gonna ask
to ask you to leave good person
absolutely this is my color
Thank You Joey thank you Joe
you're very welcome you guys I'm very
generous all right you hold her yeah
this is actually he's this is a
partnership with Dungeons & Dragons so
it's just Joe Manganiello Dungeons &
Dragons death saves is the company and
right now if you're at comic-con you can
go and check that out of bait which is a
store you know in The Gaslight Quarter
and it's uh it's really cool he was
actually like actually at the register
caching people out today had to make Wow
had to make it's his summer job yeah
it's a Joe's summer job no no with a
Magic Mike residual stop coming in start
working all day and he's um he is in all
seriousness very cool very down to earth
thank you so much for bringing us up and
flow did you bring me a gift yeah I feel
like broader numbers was here well saw
this year there was a whole bit about it
literally been here they tell me you
come on my show and there's no gift I
give you too sir I meant to challenge
you to a push up off oh boy
okay you know I feel like I actually oh
please go please yes I think you all are
underestimated
thank you think you could be Joel marina
and roll cuz I did your screen push-ups
it's flying high ever since
and action that's one and one I would
count Roly
- what is your strategy for these
push-ups breathe okay you got a full
smile on are you just trying to have
your face like your body out yeah I'm
like you know what you're just
advertising me right now get away
sure what's the last time you went to
the bathroom see Barney did
Joel fun fact about him he's only
comedian who's never inhaled a carb
before he's here pure protein and it's
just glucose goes into his body 24
that's it sure wins Wow and he's still
going it's just showing off so this was
just just fade to black and then it'll
say executive producers Jeff Ross there
will be canceled yeah I think yeah I
think you did a lot more than I could
out of him and you guys were running
around all day we essentially asked you
guys in - yes okay and baskin-robbins
flavors good job Joey we've killed Joe
Joey you win Joey your gift look Joey Oh
giving you a gifted these shirts and
this what is this this is a wishing well
I think the more you put a penny around
in it and also a puppy and also pop
bigger Joe's also because he was at Hall
H all day makin Conan waiting in the
line yes absolutely
it's only 30 minutes guys so we have
Joel waiting in line at a Hall H just
take a look at that
hey guys Joel here I'm here with more
for your Hall H line thing this is the
Doctor Who panel line and it's bigger on
the inside
it's
I know Janos that's what I like to call
an nonsense because it is a reference to
the show but doesn't make a whole lot of
sweeping around the inside that's the
phone booth from Doc TARDIS TARDIS
TARDIS what so that was the Doctor Who
panel it's actually have you not heard
that no what does that target Borla oh I
know oh I'm with you
cool what's the what Doctor Who it's a
real thing okay it's a time machine
space machine you know but it's really
exciting Doctor Who for everybody who
doesn't know is that was the panel I'm
so out of breath you are a mistake but
no it's really cool the the new season
the new series rather is starting in the
fall and it's really exciting it's the
13th iteration of a duck of the doctor
and this time it's a lady for the very
first time all right yeah and then you
got to see a Doctor Who companion you
didn't eventually get inside well let's
put up the picture and I'll walk with
you because you just met Sarah I am the
companion in this and that is Jody that
is a Lego Jodie Whittaker who is the
very first female doctor who looks a
little bit like Hillary mmm am I wrong
on that when he got it it's like a Lego
Hillary looks like when she disappeared
into the woods they put they rolling
that out and like she he's holding a
blackberry dam but yeah they tease to
some footage of Jody as the new doctor
that yeah he new companions they've got
coming out Chris Chibnall is the new
showrunner it's it's a really exciting
time to be Doctor Who fan I'm really
psyched and that is the whole line was
before that I was a giant literally
hundreds of people waiting to ask
questions like you know yeah it was
really hard I wanted to do a lot of bits
with the people in line but yeah who
would have thought that fans of a quiet
British sci-fi show would not would be a
little camera-shy little camera-shy also
it's like you know it's a bad time we
show up to
line and they've already built tents
yeah like you're gonna be here a while
lots of people had some insane setups of
like just like full seats and television
screens that they were playing video
games on it was crazy
electricity yeah they really do their
own economy their own language they
developed a full history many of their
own new arts it was crazy yeah I hang
back I hung back all day here at the
Spreckels theater where where we're
broadcasting from on the rooftop
actually we've got to hang out in
rehearsal today and I went downstairs to
the Conan green room and just like every
time you go down to the Conan green room
there was a half-naked man doing a
handstand too and I had to learn so more
for your comic-con green room thing take
a look hey guys from rehearsal they're
setting up for the guest segment right
now
I'm gonna take you down to the green
room so this is after they come to the
stage show up or something
to the green room this is what kind of
request he requests a very buff during a
handsome and gets him excited for that's
incredible how long did it take you to
learn that 20 minutes ago all right so
first I was on the Platinum part on the
ground this is a flat part yeah come if
you have no muscle definition
what's the matter doesn't matter doesn't
matter there's a one leverage really
hard oh wow feet together
push yourself a little taller pushes
have a little talk from them from the
arms and bring your shoulders this way
more okay good that's legitimately clear
sign I've ever been your nine Direction
90 percent if we do one more give them
an understanding to do this more yes
more
exact still bring your chest it's
similar it doesn't know how to dance in
a club do that that's not a dancing club
thing really pushing your hands bring
your chest in the other way play fit
together I bring it just this way push
against them yeah even more even more
even more now pushed all for five
seconds four three feet together push
taller - come on keep pushing your
wrists and breathe and breathe breathe
that was your spine supposed to make a
good shots down this wouldn't you do it
oh yes Dave yes you are Moses and I will
see you in court for the lawsuit he saw
him pushed me right give the people what
they want can't see this in the lawsuit
because then they're gonna bake Oh his
back was fine like when you catch
someone who says I'll go to choked up in
a car accident and then you see him
roller skating for sure gonna pass that
how do we safely dismount feels
incredible how many feats of strength on
the show today oh my god this is just
just a brag off yes who can do what it
was a Hunger Games themed show just
testing our agility human bodies they're
just not made to be upside down I was
made to just be like upright eating
Triscuits in a chair that's what my
entire body with look for yes but you
guys are out there tomorrow yeah on the
streets yes we are Joe anything you
excited to see I'm me I get to meet Paul
Bettany tomorrow who is famously the
vision and also the star of Wimbledon so
I'm gonna be asking for an apology from
that tomorrow when I meet him but other
than that yeah fine find me on Instagram
and DM me some questions for Paul
Bettany if you have any ok and what's
the Avengers hug bus I'm sending you
down there do you know what that is yet
oh I had no idea I was going to
something called a hug bus I know right
but it does not sound like something
I'll be able to talk about on this
livestream
oh that's what people want it depends on
how you talk about it hmm yeah I don't
think I'll be able to do it he'll think
it but marina you're going down to the
overwatch booth yes I don't really know
I'm giving you your assignment now that
you're going you go down to the
overwatch overwatch it's kind of good
that you going with no knowledge you
just take it all in one of the popular
video games just go in there and
experience for all the people that
couldn't be at comic-con you want to us
people are screaming all around us
because I think Conan is on overwatch
it's Andy Richter up there and is in his
roomie you know is screaming at himself
you're going down to the walking dead
zombies Oh
Mauro's like an exhibit down there
there's an exhibit I think so you're
going down to see exhibit he's gonna
take your car and he's gonna make it
the way you dress finally and you'll be
immediately pulled over because you know
it'll be in a traffic hazard we know
this for the shiny clothes I'm so gold
jackets so quick quick
Sun hot me you're a rotisserie chicken
right now you get the same glaze going
on all the corners you guys have been
out all day we'll see him out there
tomorrow grabbing more stuff on at Kona
khand if you're following that Instagram
they're posting all the stuff up all the
stuff that we didn't have time for you
can see all that there make sure you're
following it there and we'll be we'll be
back for another live show tomorrow
Facebook and YouTube streaming live send
us your questions also and we'll do our
best to get to them tonight on the Conan
show make sure you're watching Conan
because the cast of the new movie
predator directed by Shane Black is on
the show tonight what's the entire cast
like I was down there a little bit
watching them watching them arrive but
we got Olivia Munn keegan-michael key
sterling K Brown Thomas Jane trivanti
Rhodes
Augusto Aguilera Jake Busey and of
course director Shane Black all on the
Conan show tonight make sure you're
watching that join us tomorrow for
another live after-show we're sending
these guys back out with no sleep thank
you guys so much and follow that corner
con i'm moses storm and good day
[Music]
you
[Music]